으 으 으 으
4 알려주세요 뭐 다 10 4차 이진수 있고 잘 찍었어 요즘 온날 터
이게 대해서 얘기를 해보려고 많은데 왜
초 일은 음향 국에서 물로 다른 나라에서도 많이 하는 것 같은데 이렇게
한국에서는 어떻게 보면 굉장히 킬수 적인 꼭 이제 점수를 가지고 있어야
말하는 그런 신어 윅 어느 최근에 통 셜 바뀌어 때요 밖에 좀 더 단순한
문제들은 줄어들고
장 우 레 그럼 문제들을 눌러 왔는데
그리고 우리 스님 같은 경우에도
어 제가 듣기로는 저도 아직 취업을 나물 알지만 새로운 토익은 전체 끼로
는 이전에는 중요하기 저번 얘기 했지만 이제는 여러 새 벽에서 1 넣은거
일상에서 쉽게 사용하는 언어도 들어가 있으면서 그래프도 나오는 변심을
바뀌었다고 하더라구요 수준은 똑같다고 초에 계란은 동사들 얘기하는데
조금 낯설어서 더 어렵거나 으면 이전 토의 시험을 봤을 때 정말로 영어를
공부를 하는게 아니라 스킬을 써서 시험을 봐서 잘 반 파랑 쓸 한테는 으
새로운 유토 의 신 토익이 좀 어려울 수도 있다 라고 애교를 많이
하더라구요
그러나 제 생각에는 에 검 본격 으로 많이
들어야 많이 읽어야
많이 많이 어어 거 다 너 그거 뭐야
네 에 그렇기 때문에
제 생각에는 우리 잉 어 이용하면
* 음 자 마더 제일 좋은 방법이 그 포획에
에 왜냐하면 그 단어만 이 배우 대로
그거 뭐 맥 무 매긴다는 컨텍스트 에 쪽이 서 에 배려합니다
에그 리스트에 극 많이 배우도
의미 기억하는 것은 어려워요 맞아 그 단어 어떻게 이용하는 것은 그 이해
없어요
그렇기 때문에 우린 이 같은 방 그 방법으로 많이 듣고 많이 읽어 그 에
새로운 에 단 호 에
으 대우 기아 현대 에
제일 좋아요 이후 되면 제가 지금 하고 공부하고 오세요 냈는데요
아 새로운 단어 제각
알고 있어요 4 제가 이 한다 이렇게
사전 공유하세요 사천 사천 샀죠
요모 경우에는
아마도 2조 2형 그 에 새로운 단어 근거하는 것은
에 밤 하느 감 일 있었니 예 다음 내 하다 아무리 하다
아마도 거액의 서 백 좀 조선 단어 에 핵 짱
4 제에 경험해서
팀 cern 에 아마다 4 그 이창 방어 공부하면 때
ova 4 부터 이유 때까지 600 부초
에 7시 의 취 배까지 에
네 아마도 그가 그 백 그래프의 타지
4 그 달수 줄 수 있으며 제 생각해요
스팀 lc 생각의 정리를 하자면
스티브 씨가 지금 한국어를 공부 를 하고 있는데 스티 루시 경험에 는
지금 한 달에 4000 단어를 제 아는 단어는 세럼 안되시면 하잖아요
이런걸 비춰봤을 때 영어에서는 한다 게이 천 단어를 새로운 제알 아는
단어로 만들면
이게 토 예선 100점 과 똑같이 자유를 해서 500점 은 600점 될
수 있고 백자 뭉침을 외쳐 5일 수 있 그다음에 필요없기 때문에 현 말에
단어 쓸
어 최소한 한 최소화해 소 아래에서 하는게 4 5
그러나 그 단어 그 많이 듣고 많이 이고 도매 소
맞아요 그냥 이렇게 탐 험 양을 작업장 올라오는게 않을 r 이렇게 많이
읽어서 그 단어를 쳐 줘야 한다 연 썹니다
듣고 서정과 열심히 단 업을 만 라는 단어를 들이 그렇게 해보세요
lol 2000다 넘을 헨리 퀘스트 드립니다
예 내 강사입니다 다음 사운드가 레